2025년 중반 이후로 우리 모두가 주식을 사랑하고 있죠
반도체 AI 좋지
돈도 많이 벌고 있고 회사가 또 벌 거고
내가 공부도 많이 했고 흥분도 되고
공부해서 내가 대단한 사람이 된 것 같구나
근데 우리는 알죠
이게 언젠간 이 사랑의 끝이 있을 거고
언젠가는 주식이 빠질 거라는 거
그리고 언젠간 내 주식이 손실 나서
날 아프게 할 거라는 거
하지만 그게 언젠지는 모르겠다는 핑계로
그게 나는 아닐 거라고 생각하죠
사랑할 때도 마찬가지죠
사랑할 때 헤어질 걸 알고
또는 헤어질 걸 예상하고 그런 경우는 없으니까
시장은 좀 정리했고요
좀 불안감이 가셨는지 모르겠지만
시장에 계시는 동안은 불안감이 사라질 리가 없습니다
기쁘거나 슬프거나 좌절하거나 흥분하거나
둘 중에 하나거든요
이 세상에 들어온 순간 그렇게 됩니다
돈 벌면 막 세상을 다 가는 것 같고
내가 굉장히 마이티하게 강하게 느껴지고
이르면 한없이 쪼그라들거든요
하지만 아직은 괜찮다
폭락하는 장은 아니다
근데 점점 있다가 보면
몇 달 후에는 그런 장이 올 수도 있고
계속 트레이딩룸도 보시고
주지금도 보시고 그랬으면 좋겠습니다
오늘이 5월 15일이죠
스승의 은혜 스승의 날입니다
선생님도 되게 고생 많습니다
사실은 어렸을 때 아이들 놀이터에서
애들이랑 조금 놀면 아는데 정말 힘듭니다
선생님들 항상 감사드리고요
부모들이 못하는 걸 해주시는 거니까
그거 가르치려고 생각해 보여요
애 가르치면 정말 속 터지고
근데 제가 이 기념을 한번 찾아봤습니다
스승의 날이 뭔가
63년에 충남에 있는 청소년 적십자 단원들이
은사를 받습니다
은사를 찾아가서 감사하다는 걸 전달했던 행사였다가
65년에 세종대왕 탄생일인 5월 15일로 변경합니다
그랬다가 73년에 기념일 통합정책으로 중단을 하는데
이때 기념일 통합정책 하면서
휴일도 좀 많이 사라집니다
그러다가 82년에 부활해서 그때부터
스승의 날로 해서
5월이 이제 가정의 날 플러스
스승까지 포함해 가지고 된 거죠
스승의 날 때 그때 저희 막 선물도 많이 드리고 그랬었는데
선생님들 잘 계신지 모르겠네요
선생님 하면 다 기억나시죠
근데 이거 보고 계시는 분들 중에서도
선생님이 있을 때에
있을 텐데
그 선생님도 자기 선생님들에 대한 기억이 되게 많죠
그래서 이제 대중문화에서 나오는 선생님이
대부분 전형적이긴 하지만
저도 굉장히 많은 스승들을 거쳤습니다
저는 되게 운이 좋았던 거 같아요
제 단점 많이 가려주시고
봐주시고
잘한다 잘한다 해주신 분들이 굉장히 많았어요
이때만 해도 저희때도 많이 맞았습니다
선생님한테 뭐
체벌을 넘어서 폭행도 당한 적이 가끔 있고
근데 전 좀 이해는 돼요
왜냐면 남자고등학교 애들은 이제
거의 체격은 성인인데
여기
사람들한테
보이면 안 되니까 애들한테
약간 동물적으로 이제 찍어 눌려다 보니까
그렇게 된 게 아닌가
그리고 선생님들도 사람이다 보니까
감정이 폭발할 때도 있고
근데 그 경계가 모호한 경우가 굉장히 많죠
어쨌든
옛날 선생님들은 주로 때렸습니다 그죠
사랑이고 뭐 그냥 우선 때렸어
시험 못 봐도 때리고
아주 옛날 선생님들
요즘은 안 그러고
파바로티 이런 것만 봐도
삐뚤어진 친구들 약간 잘 해주고
굿일헌팅도 그렇고
주로 선생님들은 저는 아주 소수 빼고는
대부분 다
위하는 마음으로 시작하신다고 생각해요
대부분 다 위하는 마음으로 시작하신다고 생각해요
근데 나중에 이제
세월의 풍파를 거치면서
근데 학생들도 사실
그렇게 막
존경하고 그러진 않는 것 같아요 요즘에
그래서 좀 안타깝긴 한데
저는 예전에 선생님들이
저를
좋아했습니다
왜냐면 제가 수업 시간에 열심히 들어가지고
그렇기도 하고
반장도 하고 그래가지고
근데 좀
나중에는 좀 반항해가지고
좀 맞기도 많이 맞았는데
제가 다닌 고등학교가
약간 비연합이라고
연합고사를 보고 갈 수 있는 학교가
못 가면 오는 학교였는데
제가 이제
거기 가기 몇 년 전에 연합고사로 편입됐어요
이렇게 대전이 넓어지면서
그래서
어떻게 보면 되게 거친
학교였죠
거친 학교인데
공립에 편입되면서 이제 뭐 그랬다고 제가 알고 있는데
그래서 그런지 저희는 약간
학교폭력도 없고
왜냐면
이건 좀 과한
비유긴 한데 약간
과학고나 이런 데 비하면
우리 학교는 약간 스즈란 같은데
그랬어요
스즈란이 뭔지 아시죠
크로우즈에 나오는
그래가지고
그 안에서 워낙 이제 강한 자들이 많다 보니까
나가서 이제
다른 학교 애들이랑 싸우더라고
한때는 이제
제가 거기 배치받았을 때 저희 어머님과
저희 이제 친구들과
중학교에서 거기 배치받았다고
어떤 애는 울고 그랬습니다
내가 거기를 가다니
그리고 뭐 그 교복 입고
시내에 돌아다니면 아무도
건들지 않고 그랬었어요
득을 많이 받죠
선생님들
저희가 이제 못 찾아뵌지 꽤 됐는데
혹시 이거 보고 계시면
감사했다고 말씀드리고 싶습니다
제가 추천한 거로 물리셨으면 좀 죄송하고요
저는 그래도 노력하고 있습니다
이제 선생님에 대한 어떤 존경과는 달리
우리가 수업 시간에 보면은
선생님 존경하지
존경하고 선생님 수업에 집중하고 싶은데
이렇게 앉아있으면 졸잖아요
어쩔 수 없어
우리가 막 성장기라서
그리고 내 의지랑 상관없이 막 자
왜냐면 성장기의 청소년은
하루에 8시간 10시간을 자야 되거든요
자야 된대요
그런데 우리 못 자잖아요
우리 공부해야 되고
고등학교 때는 어쨌든 숙제도 많고
우리 애도 요즘에 12시에 잡니다
숙제 때문에
그러니까 우리 항상 이제 고등학교
중고등학교 때 잠이 부족하다 보니까
수업 시간에도 자고
그 기세를 몰아서 쉬는 시간에도 자고
다음 수업 선생님 왔는데
안 일어나고 자고 있고
어떤 선생님은 그냥 내버려 두죠
그냥 쟤는 안 돼가지고
안 되겠다 그냥 자라
그리고 어떤 선생님은 이제 굳이 깨우고 이제
뒤에 가서 서 있으라고 그러고
뒤에 가서 서서
저희 때는 이제 사물함 같은 게 있었는데
사물함에 이렇게 쓰는 척하고 또 자고
나중에는 이제 여름 되면은
그냥 반은 자고 있는 거죠
저도 많이 자는 학생이었습니다
그래서 밤에 잠이 없어가지고
저도 모르게 자고 있고
어쩔 수 없었어요
어떤 때는 이렇게 나도 모르게 이렇게 자고 있으니까
여기 침 막 고여 있고
그런 한국 친구들은 이렇게 많이 못 자는데
성인이 돼서도 못 자죠 우리
우리는 더 못 자고 있어요
커피 마시고 뭐 술 먹고
쇼쇼 보다 보면 1시, 2시 돼 있고
출근해야 되는데 6시에 일어나야 되는데 늦게 일어나고
주식하고 뭐 점심도 먹고
점심시간에 또 잠 눈치 보이고
우리는 계속 못 자는 거죠
주말에 좀 몰아잘만 한데
또 주말에도 놀러 가야 되고
그래서 못 자죠
근데 저는 수업 시간을 어떻게 활용했냐면
주로 잤습니다
그러니까 선생님들은 그
정규분포로 치면
가운데 있는 친구들에 맞춰서 진도를 빼잖아요
근데 저는 이제 이미 다 한 번 본 거였기 때문에
약간 주로 이렇게 눈 뜨고 이렇게
눈 뜨고 자는 법이 있어요
눈 살짝 감고
그래서 꼿꼿이 자는 방법이 있거든요
제 옆에 짝꿍은
꼿꼿이 못 자거든요
거짓말 아니고
저희 때는 책상이 좀 작았거든요
작은 책상인데 이렇게
이렇게 이렇게 버티고 자요
이렇게 양팔로
그러다가 이렇게 바로 이렇게 퍽 넘어져 가지고
그 친구를 이렇게 잡고
그대로 의자하고 같이 이렇게 넘어졌어요
근데 선생님이 혼내지도 않고
너 어디 아픈 거 같다고
양호실 보내고 그랬었습니다
제가 이 얘기 왜 하냐면
이제 수능이 얼마 안 남아 가지고
스승의 날 기념으로
이 얘기를 드리고 싶어요
이제부터는 고등학교 1학년부터 해야 되는데 사실은
저는 이제
공부보다
공부도 좀 했지만
110분간 집중하는 그런 걸 왜 했는지 모르겠네요
어렸을 때부터 했었습니다
왜냐하면 수능을 110분을 봤잖아요
110분 동안 시험을 보잖아요
지금 모르겠는데
저 때는 그랬거든요
우리 수업 시간은 50분 하고 10분 쉬나?
그러잖아요
50분 하고 10분 쉬고
다시 50분 하고 10분 쉬는데
실제로 수능은 110분 동안 진행된단 말이죠
그러니까 될 수 있으면
1시간 끝나고 쉬는 시간에 쉬질 않아요
그때 계속 공부를 하든가
계속 집중하고 있는 거예요
계속
그리고 다시 50분이 시작되면
그러고 나서 2시간 끝나고 그 다음 10분 쉬는 거죠
그거를 계속하면 나중에
그게 이제 버릇이 되면
마치 이제
격투기 선수들이 3분 눌러놓고
3분 하고 쉬고 그러잖아요
왜냐면 3분 동안 싸우는 게 익숙해져야
그렇게 스테미널을 유지하면서 싸울 수 있으니까
정신도 마찬가지인 거죠
집에서 혼자 문제집 풀 때도
미니멈 100분 동안은
계속 집중을 유지하는 연습을 했던 것 같아요
그래서 요즘은 학원 가도 이렇게 한다고 하더라고요
우리 애 얘기 들어보니까
그래서 지금 수능은 10분 동안
수능 생각하시는 분들은
특히 이제 전화기 던져버리시고
쇼츠 이런 거 보시면 안 됩니다
그리고 문제집 풀 때
이 문제 풀고 답이 뭐지 하면
궁금하면서 답 보면 안 돼요
수능 볼 때 그 답을 안 보잖아요
궁금해도 그냥 넘어가는 걸 익숙해
그러니까 문제집 풀 때도
이게 수능이라고 생각하고
쭉 가야 되는 거예요
그냥 체크하고 넘어가고 체크하고 넘어가고
나중에 뭐 오답노트 같은 거 만드는 거지
그러니까 그 이때부터는
실전을 계속 한다고 생각하고
그 사이클을 맞추셔야 돼요
그러니까 이제 2시간 끝나고
이제 쉬는 시간에 자야 돼요
왜냐하면 수능도
요만큼 수능 첫 교시 보고
쉬는 시간이 한 30분인가 20분 있잖아요
그때 막 친구들하고 놀고 그러면 안 됩니다
그때 누워서 자는 것도 연습해야 돼요
그때 이제 머리 쿨링하고
뭐 언어 영역 끝나면 바로
수리 영역으로 이제 모드를 바꾸는 거죠
그렇게 했었다
신기하게도 내가 왜 했지
근데 누가 가르쳐 준 것도 아닌데
저희 때는 이제 매달 모의고사를
적어도 한 번 보고 두 번 볼 때도 있었으니까
어쩔 수 없었던 것 같아요
그래서 집중을 유지해야 된다
초집중하는 게
그러면 사실 좀 졸아도 선생님들이 좋아하십니다 이렇게
눈 초롱초롱하게 가끔 초롱초롱하게 쳐다보고 있으면
강아지도 이렇게 초롱초롱하게 예쁘잖아요
강아지도 보면 시골 개들이 있어요
시골 개들이 이렇게 멍하니 있는 애들이 있거든요
그런 애들은 눈이 잘 안 가
근데 막 초롱초롱하니
나 보면서 막 헥헥 이렇게 하는 애들 있잖아요
귀여워 엄청
엄청 귀엽고 예쁘고
사람도 저도 이제 강연 같은 거 보면
가만히 이렇게 있는 친구가 있고
뭔지 모르겠지만 계속 집중하고 있는 친구가 있어요
그러면 계속 그쪽으로 눈이 가요
그러면 이제 좀 졸아도 덜 혼나고 그러니까
그리고 이제 수업 시간에 컨디션 좋으면
그 수업 시간에 얻는 게 되게 많아요
선생님들도 나름 이제 대학도 나오시고
교직원 자격증이 있기 때문에
수능도 잘 보신 분들이라서
오늘 수승의 날인데
집중 못 하셨더라도 꼭 집중하셨으면 좋겠고
수능 대비 못 만드는 법
수능 대비 패키지 만드는 법
이런 거 제가 나중에 또 말씀드리겠습니다
그리고 제가 여기 써놨죠
이 시간 활용을 되게 잘해야 된다고
그 110분을 만들어내려면
점심 시간도 잘 활용해야 되고
등하교 시간도 잘해야 되고
자습 시간도 해야 되고
화장실에서도 그러고
오답 노트 이런 것도 잘 만들어야 되고
집중하셔야 된다
약간 주제가 좀 많이 벗어난 것 같은데
네
왜냐면 제가 이 얘기 하고 싶어서 그렇습니다
몰입 이게 플로우 스테이트라고
정신적인 상태가 이제 몰입한 상태가 있거든요
뭐 어떤 사람은 게임에 몰입할 수도 있고
어떤 사람은 주로 이제
일할 때 느끼는 몰입의 힘이 있잖아요 우리가
뭔가 재미를 떠나서 몰입할 때가 있습니다
내가 좋아하는 일에 대해서
그러면 뇌에서 전두엽에서 자아의식
내가 누군지 잊어버리는 그 상태 있잖아요
내가 지금 몸이 안 느껴지고
그냥 이 컨텐츠랑 내가 하고 있는 일만 느껴지는 때가 있어요
그게 엄청 희열이 느껴지죠
주로 이제 청소년기에 많이 느끼는데
왜냐면 그때 뇌가 많이 활성화되고
많이 자극이 있고
어른 되면 잘 못해요 그죠
어른 되면 그래서 게임이 재미없어지기도 하고
책 읽어도 좀 감이 안 오고
어쨌든 이런 몰입 상태가 되게 중요하고
일부 책 같은 거 보면은 몰입을 잘하는 사람이
훨씬 더 성공을 잘한다 이런 얘기가 있습니다
몰입을 하려면 훈련해야 되거든요 정신적으로
아까 제가 110분 집중하는 훈련하는 것처럼
몰입을 하려고 해도 훈련을 해야 되는데
이렇게 막 출퇴근하고
지하철에서 쇼츠 보고 머리코미스 보고
집에 가면 또 뭐
야구 좀 보고
밥 좀 먹고
그러다가 쇼츠보다 잠들고 이러면 안 돼요
몰입을 못 해요
사실은 쇼츠를 계속 보면
아까 110분 유지하는 게 아니고
끊어서밖에 생각을 못 하기 때문에
집중력이 굉장히 떨어지고
뭐 어떤 연구 결과는 뇌가 퇴화한다
이렇게 말씀하시는 분들이 있는데
아직 밝혀진 건 아닌데
그래서 옛날에는 이렇게 손오공도
그 우주 가면서 수련장 같은 데서
중력을 50배로 늘려 가지고 하고
폐관 수련도 하고
졸호도 이제 폭포소에서 이렇게 하고
장소를 바꿔야 돼요
회사도 시끄럽고
우리 집도 시끄럽지만
정신만 차리고 있어야 돼요
절대 안 됩니다
그 물리적 세트 자체를 바꿔야 되고
우리가 할 수 있는 건
요즘과 최선이죠
절에도 가고
요즘에는 이렇게 방학 때
사찰에서 이렇게 독서실을 운영한대요
그래서 애들 비빔밥만 먹이면서
계속 밥 먹고 독서실에서 공부하고
밥 먹고 독서실에서 공부하고
옛날에 저도 이런 독서실
저는 초등학교 5학년 때부터 독서실 다녔어요
거기서 공부하고
공부라기보다는 약간 계속 앉아 있었던 건가
그리고 도서관도 가고
대학교 때는 도서관 많이 가죠
그리고 요즘에 스터디 카페가 있는데
저는 가끔 책 읽으러
조용한
거 같을 때 가는데
아저씨가 가면 별로 안 좋아하더라고요
노트북도 못 쓰고
그래서 좀 카페로 많이 가죠 요즘에는
뭐 스타벅스나
근데 스타벅스도 오래 있으면 좀
지난번에는 제가 일하러 갔는데
제일 집중을 못 하는 게
앞에서 커플이 싸울 때
주변에서 커플이 싸우면
뭔가 모든 사람들이 거기에
귀를 기울이고 있는 그런 느낌이 들어요
나도 모르게 나 일이 안 돼
계속 그 살짝 슬끔슬끔 보면
그 표정이 있잖아요
그 특유의 싸울 때 표정이 있거든
무슨 일인가 계속 그래서
그래서 커플분들은
카페에서 싸우지 않았으면
카페에서 싸우지 않았으면 좋겠습니다
다른 사람들한테 방해가 되거든요
나가서 싸우세요 나가서
공원 같은 데서 알았죠?
우리는 이 정도가 최선인데
사실은 우리가 어떤 정신적으로
우리만의 공간을 만드는 데가
독서가 제일 좋아요
왜냐면 몰입하는 게
독서가 몰입 상태로 가는
최적의 튜닝이거든요
그래서 어렸을 때부터
책을 많이 읽으라고 하는 게
영상보다는
책을 읽으면
뇌에서 시뮬레이션을 돌리는 거예요
시각적으로 정보를 받아들이는 거 말고
텍스트를 읽으면
그걸 상상할 수밖에 없잖아요
그래서 공감각적으로
냄새
이런 것들을
뇌가 내 머리에서 구현하는 거기 때문에
눈으로 보면 그냥 바로 보이는 거니까
그래서 책을 많이 읽으면
어떤 뇌도 많이 발달하고
아이들도 책 굉장히 많이 읽었으면 좋겠어요
그래서 저도
도서팀장이라는 자리를 굉장히 좋아하는 거고
저도 책을 되게 좋아하는 편이죠
그래서 책으로 좀 정보 전달도 하고
책을 많이 읽는 세상이 됐으면 좋겠는데
점점 이제 책하고는 좀 멀어지는 세상에 대해서
좀 안타깝긴 합니다
하지만 제 생각에는
앞으로 이제 성공한다고 할까
약간
우위에
서려면
AI 다루는 기술 플러스
책을 많이 읽어야 될 것 같아요
내 머리에서 어떤 상상해낼 수 있는 능력이 있어야 되는데
책을 읽으면서 수련이 되거든요
그리고 누가 그러잖아요
전 세계 위인들과 대화할 수 있는
가장 좋은 수단이 독사다
이렇게 말씀하시잖아요
저도 그렇게 생각하고
아까 몰입이랑 마찬가지예요
책도 굉장히 몰입해서 읽을 때는
내가 잘 안 느껴지거든요
결국은 자아가 확장되는 느낌
새로운 삶을 한번 경험하게 되는 거잖아요
다음 책 나오면 많이 사주시길 바랍니다
이 책도 좀 보시고
제가 가끔 좋은 책 있으면 소개시켜 드릴게요
저도 읽고 나서 같이 나누고 싶다고 생각하는 책은
가끔 소개시켜 드리고
다음 책 나오면
지난번에 안 사신 분들은 꼭 사주시기 바랍니다
책이 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
책을 읽어서 굉장히 몰입하면
후위증이 있습니다
후위증
그런 얘기가 있잖아요
한 권의 책만 읽은 사람이 제일 위험하다
왜냐하면 그걸 너무 내재화하기 때문에
그리고 뭐 히틀러 나의 투쟁 책 같은 거 읽으면
뭐 엉망진창이긴 하지만
거기 경도되면 위험하잖아요
그래서 영상 보고 읽으면
보고 막 그렇게 막 감화되고
경도되는 사람은 없는데
책을 읽으면 되게
그래서 약간
공산당 계열 책들이 좀
사상 책들
이런 것들이 조금 위험한 게
되게 막 들끓게 하는 그런 게 있거든요
자본주의 책은 들끓게 하는 게 없습니다
좀 시니컬해지거든요
그리고 종교도 그렇고 경서도 그렇고
근데 약간 문학 쪽에서는
젊은 베르테르의 슬픔이라고
괴테가 천칠백칠십사 년에 출판한 건데
원래 괴테가 이때는 그냥 고만고만한 작가였는데
베르테르라는 젊은 귀족의
사랑 얘기예요
바람 피우고 이런 얘기입니다
사실은 지금 보면
아침드라마에 나올 정도인데
그냥 먹고 살만 하니까
이 사람 저 사람이랑
자기는 사랑했다고 딴에 생각하다가
결국은 마지막엔
사랑의 상처가 너무 깊어서 자살하거든요
그 책을 읽고 유럽 사람들이 열광을 하는 거죠
이때 약간 좀
낭만주의적인 그런 때가 있었는데
그래서 이 베르테르가 입고 다니는 옷이
책에 있었는데
뭐 삽화도 있긴 했지만
그 옷을 따라 입고
한 2천여 명이 이제 이거를
따라서 자살했다는 얘기가 있어요
정확히 통계적으로는 안 나오는데요
어쨌든 굉장히 큰 유럽 사람들한테
몰입하게 만들었던 거 같아요
그래서 후유증이 있죠
이런 사회적 파장이 좀 있었고
사실 이제 그 덕에 우리나라도 롯데가 생긴 겁니다
베르테르가 좋아하는 분이
샤를 롯데거든요
롯데가 이제 그 롯데예요
껌이라면 그 롯데가 그 롯데예요
좋아하셨대 창립자께서
그래서 몰입은 되게 좋은 겁니다
몰입은 굉장히 좋은 건데
이상한 데 몰입하거나
몰입하고 깨어나면 좀 후유증이 있어요
이상한 데 몰입하면 이제 뭐랄까
삶이 정교같이 되는 거고
그게 나쁜 쪽이라면
근데 좋은 쪽으로 몰입하면
굉장히 좋은 쪽인데
몰입하고 나면 어쨌든
내가 이제 일정에 살짝 타라 했다가
다시 돌아오는 거잖아요
그래서 후유증이 좀 있고
가장 지독한 몰입이 사랑인 거죠
이거는 이제 남녀간의 사랑 말고도
일반적으로 사랑하면은
마치 어떤 가사도 있는데
나 자신보다 더 사랑했다
막 이렇게 얘기하잖아요
그때는
나중에는 안 그렇지만
그때는 나보다 더 사랑하는 상대가 있던 거예요
나랑 이제 물리적으로 완전히
단절된 어떤 개체인데
이거는 이제 책 제목입니다
사랑은 이제 완전한 몰입을 요구하고
그게 지난주에 말씀드린 것처럼
DNA 때문에 그런 것일 수도 있지만
문화적인 영향도 좀 큰 것 같아요
어떤 문화에서는
일본 같은 경우는 이제
약간 사랑한다 이런 얘기는 또 잘 안 한대요
우리나라는 근데 이제
격정적인 사랑을 주로
문화적으로 권장하죠
권장하고 그게 사랑이라고 하는 경향이 있습니다
우리나라 드라마 같은 거 보면
자신의 무가치함을
사랑이라는 우상으로 메꿔야만 하는 게
지금 우린 것 같아요
이제 우리는 종교도 없고
내가 무슨 존재인가
를 스스로 납득시키고
남한테 납득시키는 게
예전에는 종교가
있으면 무슬림 같은 경우는
신에 의탁하는 경우가 많잖아요
지금 이제 우리 가족의 틀이 되게 약해졌어요
예전에는 무슨
해줘 오씨 어쩌고 저쩌고 이런 것도 있었고
가족이 우리를 지켜줬는데
이제 그렇지도 않고
어떻게 되게 파편화 돼가지고
세상이 그렇게 됐죠
그러다 보니까
사랑함으로써 어떤 내 자신을
지탱하거나 증명할 수밖에 없는
그런 상황이 됐죠
제가 그렇게 생각한 게 아니고
분석한 거를
저도 보면서
그런 거 같다 라고 생각했습니다
그래서 저희는 이제
남녀 간의 사랑도 하고
부모 자식 간의 사랑도 하는데
지금
요걸 보시는 분을 포함해서
우리가 가장 사랑하고 있는 게 뭔가
라는 생각을 했어요
주식인 거 같아요
지금은
특히 이제 AI로 가는 반도체로
놓여진 길
요 길을 우리가 사랑하는 거 같아
AI가 어딘가 있을 거 같아
AI가
나는 보이는데 넌 안 보이니?
그러면서
AI가 될 거 같아
그리고 그 길에는 반도체가 반드시 필요해
난 그 위에 타고 있어야겠다
2025년 중반 이후로 우리 모두가
주식을 사랑하고 있죠
그리고
요즘에 이제 하이닉스랑 삼성전자에
굉장히 편해하고 있는 거고
제가 이제 이쪽에 그런 썼는데
반도체 AI 좋지
돈도 많이 벌고 있고
회사가 또 벌 거고
내가 공부도 많이 했고
흥분도 되고
매일매일 뭔가 뿌듯하고
내가 해낸 거 같고
공부해서 사서
내가 대단한 사람이 된 거 같기도 하고
근데 우리는 알죠
이게 언젠간 이 사랑의 끝이 있을 거고
고통이 그 증거로 남을 거야
이거는 제가
한강님 오마주 한 겁니다
저희도 알죠
언젠가는 주식이 빠질 거라는 거
그리고 언젠간 내 주식이
손실 나서 날 아프게 할 거라는 거
그리고
2차전지 테마가
영원하지 않을 거라는 걸 알아
하지만 그게 언젠지는 모르겠다는 핑계로
그게 나는 아닐 거라고 생각하죠
사랑할 때도 마찬가지죠
우리가 사랑할 때 뭐
헤어질 걸 알고
또는 헤어질 걸 예상하고
뭐 그런 경우는 없으니까
주식도 마찬가지인 거죠
우리가 주식을 지금
어떤 식으로 사랑하고 있냐면
또는 어떤 식으로 바라보고 있냐면
제가 볼 땐
그 전에 2023년
2024년은 되게
시니컬하게 봤어요
주식을
아 기시가 그러면 그렇지 뭐
현대차
삼성전자 막 조롱하고
지금은 네이버 정도나
좀 조롱하는 건데
그때는
뭐 한국 국장이 그렇지
박스 피인이
그랬는데 지금은
그 반작용 때문인지 모르겠지만
훨씬 더
사랑하는 쪽으로 확 갔어요
근데 이제
제가 볼 때는 이제는
오늘쯤은 조금
다시 기억해야 되는 거죠
우리는 계속
실패하는 존재라는 것
그 생각을 못 하면
계속 실패만 하고
끝날 수도 있다는 생각을 해요
그래서 조금
겸손해질 필요가 있다
이때쯤
그리고
놓을 때를 알아야
다음 사랑을 할 수 있는 거예요
이게 수남매의
어떤
진리입니다
이 테마를 놓을 줄 알아야
다음 테마를
살 수 있는 거예요
근데 계속
편한 거
이미 마음도 없는 거
이미 나도 사실 안 믿고 있는 거를
계속 잡고 있어봐야
안 돌아옵니다
돌아와도 이미 망신창이고
그래서
놓을 때를 알아야 된다
이제 왜 제 생각인 거고
우리가 생각하는 AI는
이런 거 같은 거예요
벽에 붙어 있는 바나나 우유
이거의 가치를
누군가는 인정하지만
누구는 인정하지 않아요
제가 드리고 싶은 말씀은
인공지능 가겠죠
근데 그게
우리가 생각하는 그런 어떤
구체적이고
그런 미래가 아닐 거예요
우리가
지금 또 굉장히
되게 정교한 세상에
살고 있거든요
지금
유튜브로 지금
실시간으로
개인이 하는 방송을
보고 있잖아요
10년 전만 해도
이러지 않았잖아요
근데 지금
뭐 엄청나게
하이테크고
세상이 달라진 것처럼
느껴지나요
아니잖아요
심지어 AI가
개발된다고 해도
우리 삶은
그렇게 달라지지 않을 거예요
제 생각엔
왜냐면 그 기간
시간이 너무 길다 보니까
익숙해져
갑자기 AI가
빵 나오는 게 아니고
그럴 가능성이 있다
그래서 이렇게
놓을 줄 알아야
잡지만
이거를
탁 쳐야
다음 사람을 할 수 있다
내가 비유적으로
말씀드리고 있는 거예요
국장도
언제나
날라가는 건 아닙니다
언젠가는
주식 상승을
바라는 사람들이
적어질 수 있고
언젠가는
메모리 사이클이
끝날 수도 있고
그때를
저희가
피해가야 되는 거죠
그리고 좀 쉬다가
다시 다음 사이클을 타고
봄날은 갔습니다
제가
수요일에
이 랩을 하면서
느낀 건데
코스피는 8초
코스닥은 1,200
하지만
미계자는
여전히
바다
제가
이거를
불렀는데
약간
발음이
별로라서
전달이 좀 됐으면
좋았을 거라고
생각했지만
봄날은 갔어요
봄 끝났고
이제 여름입니다
뜨거운
주식 시장도
이제
열전이 시작될 거예요
제 생각엔
여러 가지 상황상
이미
많이 들끓었고
이미 많이 물렸고
이미
매크로는 많이 망가졌고
기업 실적도
끌어올 수 있을 만큼
다 끌어왔습니다
지금 가격에
그래서 이제
더운 여름이 시작될 거고
여름에는 엄청 덥다가
소나기도 오고
그리고
꽤 열받는 일도
꽤 있을 겁니다
하지만 다시 옵니다
이게
작년 7월에
저희가 주지금에서
방송한 건데
니디님이
이때 자기 계좌 가져와서
이런 식으로
약간 자주적으로
되게 못했다
지금 보면
SK가
에닉스가
가지고 있었어요 그때
그때 141%지만
삼성전자
마이너스였는데
봐봐요
SK 하이닉스
삼성전자
LG 이노트
두산 에너빌리티
LG 디스플레이
SK 네이카우
빼고
네이버 카카오
LG 생활공간
빼고
LG 전자
이마트
보르노이
다어
장난 아니죠
그렇죠
다시 옵니다
돌고 도는 거니까
그래서
오늘 좀 속상하셨더라도
속상한 것도
이 과정 중에 하나예요
어떤 이 순환의 과정 중에 하나
투자의 일부입니다
그러니까
속상한 것도 좀
마음 주말 동안에
갈무리 하시고
하지만
방심하시면 안 돼요
다음 주 월요일에
대응해야 될 수도 있으니까
고민 많이 하시고
주말에 좀 정리하시고
대응하시면 좋을 것 같다고
생각하고요
저는 쇼쟁이
음모론자고요
제가 드리는 말씀은
가려서 들으셔야 됩니다
그리고 뭐
제가 막
잘 안 되라고
그러는 거 아니에요
그러니까
너무 미워하지 마시고
트레이딩 룸은
마치도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다